everywhere we go there's people
accepting this beautiful way of light
they figured out the purpose of life
they're living it and we hooked up with
Jack Jack were you from you're an
Irishman here or no no England no yours
Englishman no Manchester what's your
story in a condensed version why did
your system there's got to be some kind
of purpose of life I'm saying and they
teach you in school just to make the
money get the best job but when you look
out the window you see the stars you
know there's got to be more than just
making money having a good time and then
die when you look at the order you know
the animals you know the heavens and the
earth so you know I started to think
about that sort of stuff and you know
I've been to the masajid you know I've
been to temples I've been to churches I
looks into different things and I you
know I came to the conclusion you know
that there's no god but Allah and we've
got the you know the Quran makes
arguments that uh you know if there was
God's besides Allah then surely there
would be disorder in in heavens and the
earth you know one would try and
overcome the other you know if you've
got two kings of one country they're
gonna fight and cause chaos sort of fact
that disorder it proves to us that there
can only be one creator you know so
these rational arguments it's not like a
blind faith mm-hmm you know what I'm
saying so when I heard these type of
things I just accept you know we got the
clear proof you know we've got the clear
proof and you know the clear evidence
which is good in the heavens and the
earth and also within your own
intelligence you know what advice do you
have for people who have all these
misconceptions about Islam Islam is this
Islam is that you know what advice do
you have for them to tune in and what
would you tell them I just say to them
you know don't really blind follow what
you hear in the media you know that's
why I that's how I started off on my
journey you know you know these people
the politicians the media they're not
really trustworthy you know they like to
lie a lot so just try and find out the
truth for yourself you know try and find
out the truth for yourself is very easy
you know people just see something on
Facebook and then they share it they
don't look into it
you know what I'm saying they just take
blind follow so you know don't be a
sheep and at least do the research then
you can find out if you like it or you
don't like it simple sort of do the
research on just copy and paste and yeah
yeah yeah how about pick up the Quran
for your saw yes and that that's a good
idea or listen or you can listen online
and you find it very peaceful you know
yeah beautiful I think like he was
purpose of life why am I here where am I
going we're all going we have an
expiration date the milk in your fridge
got an expiration date what about you
thank you
lake wa south